what if Thunderbolt Ross kidnapped his
family and forced Clint Barton to go
back to be an assassin for him we know
like MCU doesn't keep every character
true to the comic so it's like they're
willing to change things up good job
Tommy Tommy you crushed it we love
[Music]
this is rogue theory today we're talking
about the new Black Widow trailer we've
all been goofing baños teens about what
really happened and the like but really
also who might really be wearing that
skull mask and that's where we're really
gonna get into with our guests with
these eric boss tom eric boss they get
more experiments as we go Tommy back to
[Applause]
marina master Oh tell me you can speak
this episode we're also going to talk
about the mandalorian and also what's
going on behind that mask or helmet a
lot yeah how many is he hiding back
there but first big deal trailer for
Black Widow I loved it immediately I
love David Harbor I think that is so
funny I think they're gonna go for like
an Incredibles vibe like dad daddy
incredible yeah I also loved it like
Super Soldier Serum is way better in the
u.s. suggestin the Russian knockoff like
doesn't prevent you but that is our
first glimpse at red guarding now but
also of Yelena biloba and then the
taskmaster shot that we theorized was
gonna be the villain of this movie but
we still don't actually know anything
about how they're interpreting
taskmaster in Black Widow really cool
character and marble in general I can
simply think of him as a copycat
basically but in this movie who's he
gonna be how are they in use them that's
your theories well use keep saying he
thank you for doing it away from the
table we apologize to the PA who has to
lay on the drop back in your cup yeah
you keep saying he but I actually think
it's milena
this is why so the KGB often like once
you've become not useless or you aged
out or like you break a leg or whatever
like basically if you're not super
useful anymore then they they go boink
and they kick you out the KGB goes off
of horse racing rules where you break
your oh yeah I kicked you out you need
to have a Triple Crown or they kick you
out of and so she she ages out basically
of the KGB and she becomes really
resentful
so she but she also has these same
abilities right so she is the one behind
the mask and she's going around now
she's free she can do whatever she want
inch whatever she wants and she's taking
it out on the people who you know
betrayed her essentially because she has
given her whole life to this cause and
then all of a sudden because she like
what turns 40 and has a few wrinkles
[Laughter]
it's like you know and Lord of the Rings
when it's like no man alive and
everybody thinks like oh it's a man it's
a man's man and it's and we know like
MCU doesn't keep every character true to
the comic so it's like they're willing
to change things up oh no I love it
being women it also is the story you're
describing is the one trope from recent
spy movies that I actually am totally
down with where it's all like the the
old spy comes back to get vengeance
against entire spy organization yeah but
sometimes it's the you know our good guy
it's our Ethan in Mission Impossible or
something and then sometimes it's you
know someone who we've never heard of
this person in there yes but in both of
the scenarios what's always really good
about it and match it up with taskmaster
powers is this is the ultimate threat
because they're exactly as capable yeah
and she knows everything from the inside
out that's right yeah and it's like that
whole thing when the Soviet Union
started to collapse there's the fear
that there would be a lot of rogue
agents you have like access to nuclear
arms or have like insider information
who are like one I hate seeing my empire
collapse so they start to act out in
rogue ways that's honestly how Putin
rose
was a KGB operative Oh Alf the puppet
alien well pump it for the pewte for
Putin everyone absolute make it so thing
anyway I'm tired of seeing the
motherland you don't really but you can
do a spot know what else connection is
to the Soviet regime prominence in the
80s and people questions flashers and
people were trying to copy the shooting
and Inspector Gadget but God knows he
was a pervert oh yeah Patrick Cyprus
sleeve you don't think you use those for
pleasure once in a while once in a while
never really caught claw because he
wanted that clock alright Eric said he
likes to give it's a season of Christmas
time your claw on my neck daddy gadget
forced me to say I've been bad I'm sorry
I wish early Eric do you have a theory
I'm gonna go for a pretty rogue theory
and I'm gonna get a lot of [ __ ] for this
in the comments I don't know if I
totally buy this but I kind of like at
least entertain the notion there's a
shot of taskmaster in the trailer
wielding a bow and arrow and you could
argue oh maybe you just learn that skill
from Clint Barton in the past what if it
is Clint okay so just go with me on this
maybe this is after Civil War right and
Clint Barton is was part of so all of
team cap has gone fugitive right but
some of them have just gotten arrested
and are now in house arrest
Scott Lang in Clint Barton now we
see really what happened with Clint in
the in the years in between he just had
an ankle bracelet living on his farm
what if Thunderbolt Ross kidnapped his
family and forced Clint Barton to go
back to be an assassin for him and
that's what taskmaster is he's like I
don't wanna use my face for this he's
like all right cover yourself up here
but I'm going to use you unless you know
unless you wanna see your family die you
got to take out a couple targets for me
in Budapest and that's what the big
reveal is going to be because it's gotta
be someone it's not just gonna be like
Tony masters nobody it's gonna be you
put someone in a mask but when you
reveal them it's a heartbreaking thing
now the clue I'm using for this it's a
little loose but in Avengers end game on
Vermeer when Natasha and Clint are
fighting over who gets to sacrifice
themselves it's weird how
mirroring Clint is with movements
they're doing this weird tango it's like
he can read her moves before she makes
them he's got some task mastery at work
there so what if that was meant as a
clue setting up the fact that taskmaster
who does have a history in Budapest
we know Clint Barton is going to be
revealed in this movie somehow amazing
with weapons too right yeah so I think
that could be reveal and that's what
sent him on this place of like maybe he
gets his family back at the beginning of
infinity or during infinity war his
family dusts away and that plus all the
crimes he's committed in Budapest sends
him in this dark dark groaning yeah yeah
yeah one reason that I I'm feeling this
is is your early argument of Marvel
doesn't like to reveal you know behind
the mask of someone we've never seen
before yeah until the nature just a
mystery reminds me of the Frank griot
character coming Brock rumlow character
but played by Frank Rio coming back as
crossbones we knew he would it was it
was the big theory but they don't ever
want to waste anything so why waste this
opportunity yeah or it could be his
daughter right I think it's more likely
that there's some other work at play
whether it's someone from the Red Room
as marina suggested or maybe just like
the true Tony masters origin but if you
really want to have an interesting twist
and give Clint part and something really
fun to do in this movie that could be
really cool yeah yeah and just him I get
like almost like a rematch even though
Cigna please
I'm pretty coyly yeah a second Rogge to
you sir
Tommy toss them chop them all okay good
I'm glad that that's all I have to do
mine pulls on my borrows a little bit
from Eric so uh my theory is that the
taskmaster I actually don't think that's
gonna ultimately be the big bad guy in
this movie I think it's a it's kind of a
puppet bad guy
George puppet bad guy here with a taste
for cats and an affinity for trench
coats and fedoras no I think I think I
think it's gonna be a taskmaster is
going to be someone hired by Thunderbolt
Ross I don't think it's going to be a
Hawkeye character I think it's gonna
either be an existing villain from a
Marvel movie that we've had that that is
somewhat redeemable
or or it's going to be a character
introduced in this movie that has a bone
to pick with specifically Natasha
Romanov and then Thunderbolt Ross is
going to hire this person or coerce them
into going after her as a kind of
backdoor introduction to the
Thunderbolts in this in this universe
and then I think in the end that
Thunderbolt Ross is going to have to
work with Natasha Romanoff and probably
go over this task master character is to
take out an even higher evil that's
gonna emerge about the movie whoever's
doing the the the puppet master ring not
a taskmaster I mean you got it you got
to throw a guess as to that's that
really is I hate to say Willy Wonka
because I don't know if he's cannon but
I know I'm thinking you know possibly a
Doctor Doom okay maybe it's like a big
bet I think it's gonna be another bad
guy glimpse into like someone that could
be in the kind of main through line of
what does it face for now then we're in
ideaa it could be the introduction of
the big bad guys time you get one Rogi
to start because I'm super into the idea
that taskmaster is not a red herring but
kind of not going to be as important
scenes that also has the crossbones vibe
to it to where the he wasn't really was
it was a Robert Redford yeah
a villain there but then I'm gonna give
you another little baby quarter Rogi
because I really like this idea even
though it's off clearly have to cuff of
Doctor Doom because something that none
of us do even though we theorize like
crazy every week is talk a lot about
instead of you know how do we get to
Fantastic Four or x-men or anything we
can we go so direct those ways we could
backdoor that whole introduction through
their villains instead which makes a lot
of sense someone like dr. doom who is a
you know political presence and as a lot
of money he's like has a lot of
influence in the world he's a lot easier
to bring in them then you know a
superhero team that we haven't known
about yeah yeah and it's something that
we want more I think we're all eager to
have a good Doctor Doom then we are very
good Thunderbolts personally so let us
know in the comments which of these
you're your most in line with of what
this is what is actually going to be the
story of taskmaster
marina give it to us on sweet
taskmaster he think again it's a she
Melina yes the same word the same word
guys we get drunk yes you did the my
tweet is also female and it's hash tag
hash tag she Molina's tag hash tag yeah
this is the beginning of the episode
right it's always it's always the tweet
version that what's yours
Clinton Barton if you want to see your
kids again pack up for Budapest because
we got some tasks that need master sexy
as hell
they need a task I go in the double yeah
and then Tommy what's yours oh I don't
know off the top of my head I would say
boss Ross employs taskmaster to bask in
the glory of black widows story yeah did
bask was that an internal rhyme with
tasks yes it was mine is just worlds
away yes master
he's writes for hours before T's up no I
wrote this yesterday without knowing
what we're talking thanks so much for
people helping us put on this ridiculous
show hey guys Eric here just another
reminder if you want early access to all
of our Star Wars content of which we're
doing so much breakdowns of episodes of
the Mandalorian on Disney plots an
in-depth rewatched series of the classic
Star Wars films original trilogy and
prequels and of course all the news you
need to know about the rise of Skywalker
you're really gonna want to subscribe to
our podcast feed WikiLeaks I know we're
kind of proud of the name that way
you'll be the first to be alerted when
new Star Wars information comes out from
us and you'll be able to consume this
content while you're doing other stuff
like driving working out cooking or
realistically I know what you're doing
with your time practicing your
lightsaber skills again subscribe to
WikiLeaks wherever you get your podcasts
guys we are watching and loving the
Mandalorian it is so good and it had no
need to be we would have got done a
great job of fleshing out Mandalorian
culture in general which is one of the
most fascinating kind of races or types
of people in the Star Wars universe
honestly because there's so many
unanswered questions about them I mean
even Boba Fett himself right is just a
character from a Christmas special
people like that's the most interesting
thing I've ever seen put him in
everything he's not even a Mandalorian
right so they wouldn't be making such a
big deal about what's going on with the
Mandalorians helmet I think unless there
is building up to some sort of revealed
either about this character specifically
or about all of these people or
or maybe not people but that's for you
guys to pitch to me actually what are
your rogue theories about what's really
going on behind that helmet okay well at
the most recent episode spoiler Wonder
for anyone who hasn't seen it yet but
it's so easy to find you can talk about
that he does take off the helmet
sometimes he doesn't leave it on and
then smush his food into it it's just he
doesn't take off food processor
mouthpiece he he does take it off and we
actually see him take it off as he's
watching kids play eight feet away it
could be easily turned to be like but um
so that's why I think you're onto
something that is going to be like a
reveal it's and I think I was wondering
like they cast petrol pascal in this
he's a smoke show and then a model walks
through it and makes blue steel yeah and
then his head gets mushed I think like
the reason he was casting this was
because I think again Game of Thrones
and he's cast because he's a handsome
man who gets its face bleak mutilated
what if he's just like a big I go what
do you take for this night it is like
they cast ketchup ass got to be the
voice but what if it's just like Bruce
Willis under that helmet Bruce Vilanch I
know you're watching oh I'm so sorry
oh but also you did to Eric dirty once
he did let me write for the awesome
once okay but not Bruce Wayne's but what
if he's just like not human what if he
has like he's a different race and I was
thinking like what would be the coolest
kind of reveal that's not like oh he's
been scarred and he's self-conscious
about his scar I don't think that would
be the case but what if like he doesn't
want an association like there's some
kind of shame to it we see that kid in
the flashback scenes and you're thinking
that's Mandalorian what if that's not
the adult mando
what if mando is the other kid who saves
that kid is the same race as Maul he is
a SAP rack and he has like red skin
horns and he's just kind of weird
working and because of the association
with mall or maybe because it's trying
to flee mall who was active and alive at
least from an earlier time yeah he wears
he's a foundling and he adopts the
Mandalorian culture and when he takes
off that helmet
the reason is gonna take off to the end
of the series is to scare baby Yoda away
from him alright fine this is a face of
a demon and it's gonna be like that
scene like an air bud was like get out
of here come on don't you see an away
anymore to say baby Yoda to get him to
run away he's gonna scare him with his
rock face because Erik made baby Yoda
cry I think we're gonna have to make a
video to cry he's on probation you can
get them back by doing what I'll do
anything just walk over to the other
side of the table and grab them but I
know it's a lot of work okay I'm feeling
parts of that that essentially he's just
he's just an alien and there's a
misdirect
all his memories but you know in this
one humans are aliens it's cyber once an
alien that's true yeah everyone is
anyway so okay so I'm okay with this I'm
gonna give you just a little Rogi for
right now but I'll put it on your
probationary staff I think it's pretty
obvious that the Mandalorian is to Jawas
standing on each other's shoulders or a
tiny little alien flying around like
like lifting the arms then rushing the
other arm I think it goes down
okay we've established this parental
kind of father-son bond right now
between Mandalorian and baby Yoda like
he's kind of like sort of parenting him
a little bit I think that's only gonna
grow over the next couple of episodes
and I think what's gonna happen is it's
gonna come down to a scenario where the
Mandalorian is in peril and normally he
would choose to die honorably in battle
but if he does that he knows he'll be
also dooming baby Yoda so
he's going to have to remove his helmet
for him to live so that he can save baby
Yoda and maybe once we do that reveal I
think honestly just bottom line
financially it's gonna you know me I'm
bottom line back told its go back and
watch new rock stars from I've been
saying episodes have been scrubbed those
have been off the internet for a while
now they're in the FBI's hands justice
will be brought no but I think like
they're gonna it's gonna be a glowing
golden our shot of Pedro Pascal's face
and it's just like of course but it's
not glowing just a pro clarity right no
he's glowing okay it's gonna come off in
like a like he's gonna have to decide
like hey baby you have to take it off
and he'll be an alien life-form also
known as elf no he'll be elf do
character from the Will Ferrell yes
do you either of you have versions where
it's it's like injured or scarred face
or is it just kind of like he looks like
I want one this Blitzen nose down the
middle and I think it's gonna spell hot
okay so you just think basically that
we're getting Pedro Pascal back there
and he has to dishonorably take off his
well I think it'll be a new form of
Honor he'll be dishonouring his old ways
and kind of honoring his new ways as
this father who you know like when
you're a parent as I know I have 15 kids
your life becomes about keeping them
alive not so much about keeping yourself
alive so I think this selfless act will
be a representation of him leaving his
kind of war motivated battle weapon
centric ways of Mandalorian ISM and
moving on to something different one
time when I was very young I set a fire
in the kitchen and my dad had to run out
of the bathroom to put it out completely
panceliss
yeah and it was a new cutting of Honor
household buddy broad where I had to see
that but it was for the greater good
it's the same thing I love Philips
stories so much
you I set fire to my snowman everyone
ignored no snowmen attorneys have you
burned your snowman down the line from
Lord of the Rings okay it is Pedro
Pascal we do we do see his face
but mine is that he's a single dad who
gets to have it all so no no he gets to
have it all this is this is the this is
the hallmark movie we want and it it has
to do with his religion so because we
all know you know in the prequels Jango
Fett just walks on without his helmet on
completely they never wear helmets
before the rise of the Empire so my
theory is that the mendler and religion
changes after the rise of the empire and
that's why they go underground you can
only have one of them come up at a time
they have to never remove their helmets
because they're in hiding all the time
and their religion is now instead of not
instead of but in addition to being this
war you know culture and like you're a
fighter and that's the only thing you do
now you also have to hide you also can't
take your helmet off like that's part of
the religion and this guy is like you
know what no because if I live as a
warrior I can never have a kid okay I
can never have my career and be a parent
at the same time and I'm gonna change
that and we've already seen him inspire
different actions from the rest of the
Mandalorians when they come up a bunch
of them at a time to save his ass to
help
baby to get baby out on the plane and to
get away so they've already broken the
code for him once right so I think at
the end of this show he does take off
his helmet but it's not he doesn't not
have to be a Mandalorian anymore he's
basically making a religious statement
and saying look I'm still a Mandalorian
and everybody else can still be a
mandolin with me but I get to raise this
kid at the same time you can do both and
he's basically like the Pope of the
Mandalorians and they all start
following him and they the religion like
changes because he makes a statement
about it
gets to have it all he takes off the
helmet at the end - and he just like
goes into the sunset with his kid and
the rest of the Mandalorians also take
off their helmets and they all do it at
the say see him do it and then they're
like you know what yes and so they all
do it that's how Pope Francis became the
Pope off his hat and it became Bruce
Bruce Vilanch his phone is just back
baby need chooses phone and interesting
about that oh did I tell me did I give
you any anybody's hears no I'm sorry I
actually really liked yours yeah here
you go just a full-blown Rogge cache
said oh great job Tommy you're doing
because parents are just a boys and
we're trying to work how they separated
23 years ago for the kids
marina something I like about yours oh
is tying I mean it is it doesn't make
sense that hiding his identity and
covering himself up is tied to religion
we have those religions on earth but do
have a lot to do with what you allow
people to see of you they tend to be
gendered but in this situation it yeah
it's for safety yes I do I do really
like the idea that if he
were to eject from this religion or
start something else it would make a lot
of sense in like well what's the Hellman
matter then it's about his religious
beliefs and he knows I think he knows
that it didn't used to be that way and
so he's like back in the day right he's
like I remember seeing Django everybody
walking down street hey J what we're
focusing on the wrong parts of the name
mandalorian what if we're focusing too
much on the man duh but really it's all
about the Laurieann take the mask off
and it's Laurie Ann Robinson VP of
accounting at a local Cloud City law
firm is that the craziest rogue theory
of all bring them over
Eric's quarter Korean are you having
some droids do your paperwork for ya
Laurie Ann she's not in her office where
could she be on a epic Galax galactic
adventure with baby Yoda maybe this dog
eats avocado this is just like the old
the doctor is his mother we're all just
assuming the mandalorian is some
strapping man that's right yeah the
doctor is his mother is the story of how
you were born yes my mother was actually
the doctor I was born in the Cabbage
Patch nice and tight and then Tommy he
learned to share because he's accessing
his feelings and sharing limbs and he
gave Erik back his that's very sweet
give him back to me Hannah - he
Mandalorians single dad gets to have it
all religion and career and a son in the
new so we're so close in the new so
tired she takes a lot out of her
Eric mando takes off his helmet
revealing a scary face to make baby Yoda
cry okay my head mando hell no Laurieann
has the master plan for the lorry and
helmets off baby ory no helmet take your
helmet off baby Yoda feels grateful
mother and son have fun when the helmets
become a jar they can go far as a family
yes I like that use the word a jar
because the helmet opens that's
beautiful that's where they get the word
yeah helmet this is the hardest part of
the show honestly guys the hardest part
is deciding where to put your current
point totals that oh you know what it's
a three-way tie because I mean put a lot
of extra effort days to that nosebleed
that she got from that tweet but your
three I will be settled by rogue
question just a billion road question
though user wishes to okay good
questions a night none of us have seen
before but we're gonna answer quickly
ready yes yes David Harbor posted the
Black Widow trailer on Instagram with
the caption Marxist Santa Claus is
coming to kick your ass which is perfect
what what would Marxist Santa Claus
leave in your stocking a stepladder so
everyone can be the same height equal
across the world when I would you would
just be consistently taller she jumped
on it probably just coal but coal would
be a good roots of the labor of some
hard-working proletariat
I think it would just be a glossary of
buzzwords about Marxism so I could feel
like I could contribute to this
conversation rather than just racking my
brain for like 10th grade economics
class and trying to sound smart Wow I'm
sorry we put you in this situation
it's fine also q-tips because my ears
get really dirty this is just for you
now
those are great Disney has made baby
Yoda dolls available for purchase but
you don't get them till April that's
dumb
you can buy them right now you don't get
them till April how will you pass a time
until your baby you at $1 arrives yeah
I'm gonna get pregnant and have a kid
and then and then when it doesn't turn
out to be baby Oded then I discard them
I reveal myself to be Darth Maul scare
the kid away like you said and then get
my baby out in the mail Wow Wow I mean
it would eat up that time the kid gets
scared away he's an infant they can't
walk so then it comes back to you know
later murder me as an adult is for
revenge oh yeah great
I love the story Cabbage Patch story by
a female doctor okay so how I would
spend four months would be wondering if
it's a real thing or an April Fool's
joke cuz nothing like feeling like an
April Fool in December or during a
Christmas present you imagined him none
of these people are real you created
your friends creating all just been a
dream ends on the dream uh tell me both
of these answer had me worried about
about how you see yourself and how you
feel about yourself at the moment oh no
no I feel very very good about myself
I'm fine I'm fine
this is alpha a trenchcoat I think
you're digging your nails into your legs
I love it guys laura dern oh it sorry
Eric
Eric well you know me I'm just gonna put
myself in dangerous
life-threatening situations front of
babies until one of them uses of course
to save me and then we form a
partnership here's is less effort than
mine
great laura dern joked in an interview
that she saw baby yoda at an NBA game oh
god laura dern with the classics
what would baby her to be doing being
all cute I mean I think we gotta check
in on laura dern like northern do you
see baby otto right now fifty years old
so he's horny he's getting the kiss-cam
if you're sitting by yourself people
would line up if there's baby oh - oh
man we can be in line keep doing that
real quick come let's go ahead and kiss
cam Tommy with your gross scouting you
know he's wise he's patient oh I know
he's looking for people that he could
use for his new franchise I love all
these answers and I'm gonna but I'm
mostly gonna acknowledge that Tommy you
worked the hardest disappered to share
what you were thinking about and your
self-esteem is is improving it sounds
like and for that you get the one Rogi
that i award for the surrounding Road
questions and Tommy is our winner
this episode of road theory so Tommy's
wish comes true I wish for one thousand
more wishes or one hug from my dad both
are priceless
only one has no chance of that but
they're both fictional yeah let's get a
hug from well Eric you do a spot-on mr.
Beck told what did I tell you about
knocking alright never knock unless
you're sure that you don't have a gun
pointed at you on the other side of the
door that's right now
i enclose that door behind you origin
story it's cold up here in northern New
York Tommy that's all we needed to take
this pervert down there cats eat you
thanks for coming with us
thanks to our guest Rayna Mastro's hey
it's fun to talk about mana learning
with a marina cuz she's going to be
stepping in to do the Mandalorian
breakdown of episode 5 yeah Eric lost a
bet so now I get to do it yeah and we're
gonna be launching a new show format
that Philip and I've been working really
hard I've been working really hard on on
Friday so yeah great
all right we'll see you in those videos
[Music]